♪♪
>> Juan: ROUND TWO TONIGHT.
TEN MORE DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES
SET OFF IN DETROIT.
BUT ALL THE EYES ARE ON THE
REMATCH OF JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA
HARRIS.
THEY HAD A TESTY EXCHANGE ALMOST
A MONTH AGO.
BIDEN NOW WARNING THAT HE WON'T
BE POLITE THIS TIME.
THAT'S ONE OF THE MAJOR STORY
LINES WE'RE FOLLOWING.
LET'S GO AROUND THE TABLE AND
SEE WHAT EACH OF US IS EXPECTING
TONIGHT.
JESSE?
>> Jesse: MY PREDICTION IS
GILLIBRAND WOULD BE VERY RUDE
AND INTERRUPT EVERYTHING AND TRY
TO ATTACK BIDEN.
SHE WILL HAVE HER TIME DOCKED
BECAUSE OF HER RUDE INTERRUPTION
BECAUSE OF HER RUDE INTERRUPTI N
INTERRUPTIONS.
BUT MY PREDICTIONS HOLD FROM
YESTERDAY.
BIDEN IS CAUGHT NOW BECAUSE HE'S
BEEN CALLED SLEEPY JOE AND HE
HAS TO REMAIN CALM UNDER
ATTACKS.
HE WON'T BE.
HE WILL OVERCOMPENSATE AND SPAZ
OUT.
ALSO, BIDEN HAS TO BE
DISCIPLINED AND PERFECT.
IT WASN'T ARE REASON THAT HE'S
SO LIKED IS BECAUSE HE'S
IMPERFECT AND UNDISCIPLINED.
THAT'S A CATCH 22 THERE.
ULTIMATELY, YOU JUST SAW, WE HAD
OPPOSITION RESEARCH DROPPED.
A REPORT FROM FOX NEWS THAT
KAMALA HARRIS ACCEPTED $5,000 IN
DONATIONS FROM DONALD TRUMP IN
2011 AT THE HEIGHT OF TRUMP'S
BIRTHER INNUENDO.
WE'LL SEE IF THAT GOES UP.
>> Juan: DIDN'T HE GIVE TO
HILLARY?
>> Jesse: MAYBE THAT WAS BEFORE
HE WAS A POLITICIAN.
>> Juan: BIDEN IS SIGNALLING
THAT HE WILL BE TOUGH THIS TIME.
YOU HEARD WHAT JESSE SAID.
WHAT ARE YOU EXPECT SOMETHING.
>> Emily: WITH BIDEN, IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT HE'S PREPPING
DIFFERENTLY.
PREPPING WITH A SMALLER GROUP OF
ADVISERS THAT ASKS HIM WHAT HE
THINKS RATHER THAN OVERJAMMING
AND JAMMING HIS HEAD WITH TOO
MUCH FOR HIM.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE A REALLY
STRONG KAMALA.
THIS IS WHERE SHE'S DEFENDING
HER CHAMPIONSHIP AND WHERE SHE
NEEDS TO BE STRONG AND WHERE I
ASSUME WE'LL SEE HER BE STRONG
IS DEFENDING HER HEALTHCARE PLAN
AND BEING SPECIFIC ABOUT IT,
DEFENDING HER CRIMINAL JUSTICE
RECORD WHICH AS A CALIFORNIAN I
WOULD HAVE TON OF QUESTIONS
ABOUT HER FLIP-FLOPPING AND I
HOPE THE MODERATOR GOES DEEP
ENOUGH AND SEEING IF SHE HAS A
THAT PRESIDENTIAL COMMAND OF
EVERYTHING.
ON BIDEN, WE HOPEFULLY WILL SEE
HIM -- HIS REACTION TO HOW IS HE
GOING TO BRIDGE THIS CIVIL WAR.
HOW IS HE GOING TO UNIFY THE
PARTY.
HE  -- HOW WILL HE BE THE
COMPLETE PACKAGE.
>> Juan: DANA?
>> Dana: SIMILAR.
BIDEN WILL BE VERY PREPARED FOR
ATTACKS FROM KAMALA HARRIS AND
CORY BOOKER.
THEY'LL BE ON EITHER SIDE OF
HIM.
SO REMEMBER, WHEN HE GAVE THE
INTERVIEW, HE SAID HE WASN'T
PREPARED FOR THE ATTACKS.
HE WILL BE PREPARED, BUT HE WILL
NOT BE PREPARED NECESSARILY FOR
SOME OBSCURE ATTACK FROM HIS
36-YEAR VOTING RECORD FROM
SENATOR KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND.
IF SHE DOESN'T MAKE A WAVE, SHE
WON'T BE ON THE SEPTEMBER
DEBATE.
>> Juan: THAT'S WHAT I WAS GOING
TO ASK YOU ABOUT.
AT THIS POINT, THEY SAY YOU HAVE
TO HAVE HIGHER POLL NUMBERS AND
MORE DONORS IN SEPTEMBER.
>> Dana: THEY HAVE ABOUT 20
RIGHT NOW ON THE DEBATE STAGE, A
FEW MORE LIKE TOM STYRE.
WE'RE NOT WHITTLING DOWN THE
FIELD.
THE VOTERS ARE.
THEY'LL ONLY HAVE TEN CANDIDATES
BY SEPTEMBER.
>> Juan: CAN YOU WHITTLE, GREG?
>> Greg: I LOVE A GOOD WHITTLE.
>> Dana: WHY SO WHITTLE?
>> Juan: GO, GREG, GO.
>> Greg: I THINK BETO MIGHT
SURPRISE US TONIGHT.
>> Jesse: IT'S BET TOE'S NIGHT.
>> Emily: HE WAS ON LAST NIGHT.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
BOOKER WILL COME OUT SLUGGING
AND PROBABLY MAKE A FOOL OUT OF
HIMSELF.
BIDEN WILL BE PREPPING WITH A
LONG NAP AND PERHAPS TALCUM
POWDER TO DRY THE CERTAIN
STRESSFUL AREAS SO HE WON'T GET
CRANKY.
AND TULSI WILL RISE TO THE
OCCASION.
I PUT MY MONEY ON HER AS A
SLEEPER.
>> Jesse: NO, SHE WON'T.
>> Juan: MY PREDICTION IS, THE
BIG NIGHT IS NOT ABOUT BIDEN BUT
BETWEEN BOOKER AND HARRIS.
BOOKER AND HARRIS GO AFTER EACH
OTHER, THEY HAVE A REAL
INCENTIVE TO SAY HEY, I'M NOT
THE ONE THAT IS TRYING TO TAKE
DOWN JOE BIDEN.
GUESS, GUESS WHAT, BLACK VOTERS
YOU SHOULD BE LOOKING AT ME.
>> Dana: DON'T FORGET THE YANG
GANG.
>> Greg: WATCH YOUR LANGUAGE.
>> Dana: WHAT DID I SAY?
>> Juan: ANYWAY, I THOUGHT --
NOT GREG AGAIN.
[LAUGHTER]
OKAY.
YEAH.
YANG WAS A DISAPPOINTMENT LAST
TIME.
>> Dana: THEY CUT HIS MIC.
>> Juan: OKAY.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DO THINK THAT JOE BIDEN HAS
SENT THE SIGNAL TO EVERYBODY
ELSE THAT HE'S BEEN DOING
OPPOSITION RESEARCH.
YOU THINK IT WAS FUSION GPS?
HE'S GOING TO SAY IF YOU BRING
UP RACE AND START TO ATTACK ME,
I'LL MENTION ABOUT MR. BOOKER,
HOW YOU HANDLED RACE AND THE
POLICE IN NEWARK AND KAMALA
HARRIS, I'D REMEMBER THAT YOU